what are some of the best ways to become
a better actor aside from being the
perpetual student in these classes that
I know we're beneficial right but you
right people can get stuck in that right
and there's always also about classes
you want to be careful of the teacher as
guru you know you really have to be
watchful for that because a lot of times
there are many classes in which the
teach it's more about the teacher and
the students adulation of that teacher
than it is about the students you know
so it's a way to become a better actor
is to act is to get on stage as much as
you possibly can and don't let any of
this New York versus Los Angeles theatre
thing dissuade you because I've seen
brilliant shows and stinkers on big in
big houses and small on both coasts so
you just have to do it
actors act if you sit around your house
and you get a play reading together with
other actors that you know and you just
read and then you celebrate outdoors
right you do that you have to do it you
know because not and interacting with
other people is just social interaction
with other people very important I think
and being not self-absorbed person is
very important because you learn things
from every experience you know being out
in the world watching the way people
move in the world listening to the
sounds of their voices and the funny
little ticks they have and the things
they do it's all about incorporating
something real into this fictional
moment that you're creating on the stage
and the more reality you can bring to it
the better you'll you'll be and here's
one thing a tip that I have found to be
invaluable and I learned this very early
on my mother was also my coach because
she was a fab and when I was doing
Shakespeare I was with the Colorado
Shakespeare Festival for two seasons
when I was a kid and she was getting her
masters there at Boulder and so I had no
idea
for everything you know she wasn't
directing them but I had to audition for
everything and I had a I like language
so I had a a proclivity for verse and so
but there were times when the verse I
didn't you know it was nine and so I
didn't quite know it didn't fit in my
mouth quite right so what I learned was
to put in my head the well it just
doesn't work with verse so much but it
helps with interpretation of anything
and in regular language this really
works if there is a line that you that
doesn't fit in your mouth well you know
rephrase that
in your head the way you would say those
that concept and then impose that rhythm
onto the sentence that you're given so I
wish I could have a facile example right
now but if it's something as simple as
you know I want you to go to the store
and buy some celery and and that doesn't
make sense to you in your head you go
you know we need celery and then you go
I want you to go to the store and buy
some celery so you say it with the music
of the rewrite that you put in your head
so you impose the music of the rewrite
on the line that doesn't fit in your
mouth and it really works Oh
does that make sense sure does it sure
does because a lot of times maybe you'll
yeah that those yeah there'll be
something that you wouldn't normally say
but if you put it in your voice yeah I
get it yeah I get it I can't really are
you really what music of your voice
now you don't put it in your words you
put it in the music that accompanies
your words you know so you're
superimposing the sound of you know we
could use some celery on a legitimate
story get some celery instead of I want
you to go to the store and get some
celery or what whatever whatever I
that's a very silly example but but it's
the concept of the tone right imposed on
the words that don't fit in your mouth
make the concept fit in your
and then put the music of that over the
words that don't fit right so if you say
things with maybe an inflection at the
end or with a question or something or
maybe you're more it's more of a
directive whatever way you're normally
sort of speaking to someone it let's
suppose in that context right you do it
and then try to fit that sentence in
yeah you put the sound of that sentence
over the words that don't fit because
I'm sure every actor has gotten a line
that good I would never say this and
this is not I can't make this real how
do I make this real so you you make it
you you reinterpret that sentence into
your own words and then hear how that
sounds in your head and put the sound of
that
on the words that don't fit and it
always it always worked for me and when
I've given it as advice to others they
said you know I like that that that
really helps because it personalizes it
it's like it makes it real right
listening to the tones of others and
that sort of thing so listen to your own
tones too and have them help you
you